Very exciting project that we're going to be starting next week and I want both of you guys to be on it.
Is that.. Ok with you Erin?
*House music plays* Yea.. Of course
*Man Speaking in the background* If I am not super diligent, the minute my face starts resting... I'm a bitch.
*House Music*
Hey Come on.. Cheer up! It's Bagel Day!
Ok just because I'm not smiling doesn't mean I'm miserable.
He sounds great...
He is Great...
That's what I meant! Do you think he's not great?
Sometimes my face has a really hard time expressing excitement... It sucks..
Oh, hey did you hear about Calvin's party, it's gonna be so fun!... There's like... You don't seem that excited about this... Never mind, it's alright.
Fuck! I'm excited... I'm excited...
Erin, we're a little worried about your attitude... We think you should smile more.
Stop saying that. I'm pretty sure it's an HR violation.
You Know... Whatsup? When I first met you I thought you hated me.. So funny..
You know... That one's kind of offensive.
Wait what's wrong?
What?
You look like something's really wrong.
I'm just thinking... Look, this is just how my face is, ok?
If this is about last night, I'm so sorry.
*House music happily continues*